Hey buddy!
Hello, hello!
It feels sort of like deja vu.
Look at this tiny little guy right here.
Silence, you are...
What do you mean?
Look at you, you saw.
Look at this little baby.
look at this little baby you know what no you should be
tired you're what do you mean shrunk for me that's your real
size yes that's your real size what do you mean
oh bro oh you sounds quiet okay let me raise you son a
little bit higher
using in-game we're using in-game mic so like uh yeah so i
have to like lower the game volume wait you scared what do
you mean no because the game volume will be louder than you
what do you mean oh my god yeah i do to be really honest i
don't really hear your voice too yeah yeah you have to lower
the in-game volume so you can hear me i have you all the way
up on voice though Is this better, guys?
Let me know if this is better.
I'm gonna...
I can turn.
Oh, I can lower the music volume.
That's awesome.
Yeah, yeah.
We can lower, like, all the game stuff.
And then...
Ooh, nice.
That's nice for me.
That's way better for me.
Awesome.
All right, how's the...
How's USAN's volume now?
Is doing it me...
It does it...
A bit louder.
Okay, eat your mic.
Eat your mic.
Yeah, yeah.
I think I'm just gonna increase my mic gain.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, what do we mean?
What do I mean?
Do I need to increase mine?
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
How about now?
A bit louder, a bit more?
Okay, I'll, I'll, I'll increase.
Ah.
Oh, God.
I'm gonna, like, when you start screaming, that's when I'm
scared.
I'm just gonna try my best to not to scream and increase.
In a horror game?
I don't want to do any drama.
dramatic scream yeah yeah because you're you're known to not
scream yeah then you know I want to focus on controlling my
sanity today oh entertaining dramatic scream you know what I
mean all right how's how's you sound is you sound better now
are you loud okay it's you loud I'm not loud okay well I'm
always loud what do you mean I'm always loud But if I'm
quiet, there's something wrong.
Alright, for those who don't know who Yuson is, they are a
very talented singer.
And...
Whoa, why do I hear myself?
Why do I hear myself?
Do I have my stream playing?
Oh.
Oh, wait.
I have my own stream playing.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, okay.
I was like...
Oh, yeah, I think it's here for a moment.
Yeah, yeah.
I had my own stream playing.
i was like what the fuck okay all right yo are you a
professional stream what do you mean i i i just started
streaming a week i just started streaming a week ago okay
anyway for those who don't know who you saw this they are
very very talented singer um and uh they released a lot of
covers you know i heard that you got noticed by a very
famous singer in japan what's her name ado ado yeah yeah you
saw got noticed by ado there was that sang that one piece
song that's the only thing i know oh my god wait uh you know
oh my god i was about to do the self-promote but you're like
doing this for me yeah don't worry i'm very i'm very good at
business oh my god well anyway guys what about yeah my cover
in bio my cover in bio all right okay your turn add okay
your turn promote me promote me you saw it's your turn i
promoted you you have to promote me on my own channel uh
nothing gremlin dragon that's me that's me what what talents
do i have What am I good at?
You're a professional gamer.
Oh my god, really?
Me?
Please, please.
Let's, you know, let's play game.
You know, actually.
No, no, no, no.
Go on.
Keep talking more about me.
Keep talking.
She has awesome laugh.
Yeah, yeah.
Go on.
She's really good at drawing.
Oh my god.
Really?
She's really good at drawing.
troller late to you know speaking with those non-native
english speaker like me oh thank you a really good listener
yeah i am yeah and mr man is awesome wow oh my gosh you
didn't have to say all of this you did not have to oh my god
that's so nice of you you son thank you and okay release me
anyway let's start the game so i've never played this game
before um i don't think you saw you played this game before
right where are we oh you saw can't hear whoa what the i
just realized you i can't even hear me we're we're what you
start talking to themselves right now
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
Oh, wait.
Where is where are they?
Okay, let me let me me Yusun Yusun Yusun?
Oh my god.
Yusun?
Oh, I'm so scared Oh What do you mean?
You're way much scared.
Oh, yeah, I look like a homeless person wait i can hear
myself from your side of the mic oh my god i think you have
your set on like on like stereo or something yeah okay hold
on a moment i'm just gonna fix that real quick okay oh my
god whatever now okay let me see yeah yeah we're good all
right okay so we gotta escape the back rooms oh i think we
have to go this way there's an arrow this way i like how you
were like talking to yourself because of the i could see you
talking to yourself I mean, you know, when you're scared,
you're just gonna, you know, try your best to, you know, how
do I say, bring your attention to something else, so you
don't have to, you know, yeah, so just, so you're, it's not
like you're alone.
This guy fucking talk.
What?
My avatar fucking talk.
Wait, we're, okay, this is not the right way.
I mean, it's not that scary so far.
okay escape as long as we're together nothing bad can happen
to us right oh way i am running out of my stamina yeah
that's why we gotta okay that's why we have to like make
sure we don't because i feel like there's gonna be a monster
here soon i don't know no no oh there is there is there is
there is there is okay use the ladder okay that's so easy
what the fuck this is a horror game No, don't jinx it.
This is so easy.
What do you mean, Yusun?
No, no, no.
Look, there's water.
Are you wounded?
Hear yourself?
We're drinking water.
Oh my god, there's what?
Wait, wait, there's walkie talkie.
Wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
We can talk to each other.
We split up.
Hello?
Okay, okay, we're fine.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
We're fine.
Get over here.
Go over here, Yusun.
As long as we don't split up anxiety, wait, what does this
do?
You spill so you used to calm me down so...
Hey!
We need one chupil.
Yeah, don't worry.
See, I saved you one.
I'm a good person.
Thank you.
Okay, you first.
You're welcome.
1, 4, 4, 7, 1, 1.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, fuck!
Fuck you!
Oh, my God!
Fuck off!
Fuck you.
There you go.
There's a dive button.
Wait, I can whistle.
Wait, you can whistle.
Uh.
Gee, gee.
How did you whistle that?
Gee.
Wait, can I whistle while I'm using walkie-talkie?
I don't...
Oh my.
Oh my god, that chit-skit.
Woo.
Scuffer.
i feel like we have to know this okay chat remember these
numbers for me two three one four or a seven one eight nine
this is your job chat you have one job remember this get
over here you son get over here okay how do we okay i guess
we go one Oh, that's what the number's for.
Why are the numbers again?
Wait, what are the numbers?
I already forgot the number.
I'm going to check real quick again.
No, no, no, no.
We're letting...
That's what chat's for.
Seven.
Seven?
One, one, three, eight.
Seven, one, one, three.
Okay, that's not right.
Okay.
Four.
Four, seven, one, one, three, eight.
4, 9, 7, 1, 1.
So some numbers are missing.
What?
Some numbers are missing there.
There's numbers missing?
I'm so confused.
Me too.
I'm so...
No, why is there a puzzle?
Why is there...
I have no idea.
Why did they make a puzzle?
Look around.
Wait, I see so many people pressing telling me to press
these numbers okay don't worry chat is backseeding you wait
but it's not working what do they mean okay seven four oh no
i already lost wait are you cheating right now no i'm not
cheating no no no this is a stream what do you mean wow what
do you mean some professional gamer behavior you're okay
gamers always ask chat for help the big I am very mature and
I'm willing to ask for help.
I am willing to ask for help.
That's when you know I am a gamer.
Okay, 1798, one.
I am so disappointed on this.
Okay, what do the numbers mean?
What do the numbers mean?
Don't do that.
Okay, then you solve this.
You solve this.
You're so smart.
Yeah, do it.
Solve it.
um so i say that some numbers are missing here like which
one uh so five so so far i know five is missing why do you
know oh okay oh because there's no five it's also missing
there's no six yeah zero did we have zero in the no it's
only one why would there be a floor zero on an elevator you
son where the fuck is floor zero what zero doesn't exist you
know yeah i'm just thinking something more logical you know
how is zero as an elevator number logical
come on you know this is something this is the teamwork you
know yeah we're gonna help each other to my teamwork is
getting chat to help come on yeah let's focus so five six
Okay, zero, no zero.
Okay, no zero.
Okay, there's no five.
There's no six.
Okay, I'll type that in.
Wait, okay, five, six, three.
What's the last one?
Seven?
What?
No, there was a seven, wasn't there?
That's not this.
It's not this.
Eight.
I don't know.
There's eight.
Seven.
There is, yeah.
It's seven, one, nine, eight.
Why is a seven, one, one?
Why is it seven?
7-1-9-8.
7-1-9...
It was not 7-1-9-8.
Who said that badness person?
No, no, this is the reason why you shouldn't trust in Chad
and it's your own mistake.
Okay?
Yeah?
Wait, look at that.
There is B.
Wait, there is B.
Yeah, but I can't press B.
Okay, look at that.
There is zero.
Look at that.
B is a letter.
is a number zero is a number b is a letter basement is
basement it's the one that be roasting me for pointing out
basement one two three four five because no one puts
basement as a zero everyone puts basement as basement
basement one two three four five three seven eight or g
ground level two three one two three four five six seven i'm
talking like that come on this is the teamwork listen This
is teamwork.
I'm educating you on elevators.
I'm trying to educate you on elevators.
Chad, help.
Look, it's basement lobby.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Wait, why is it 1987?
Where did you get 1987 from?
I'm pointing out the thing to solve the puzzle, but she
decided to roast me.
the hell okay why is it 1987 explain 1987 on the roll okay
1987 1987 oh my god we did it i told you i'm not happy with
it i'm not happy with it i'm not happy with it we did it
guys we're so smart Smart you saw questionable.
I am not.
Oh my god.
I don't want to take that bite of 87 We will never know why
we'll never know why that was the correct answer But it
worked it worked.
That's all that matters.
It worked.
I don't like this.
This is it's getting darker now We go this way Okay, let's
go.
Oh, wait, wait, do you hear that?
Did you hear that?
you first don't worry as long as we're together nothing bad
can happen wait what's this oh it's water almond water spray
can it can save you so make sure you watch your stamina it
can save you but what's this oh wait that's a new spot it
resembles resembles a dog due to the fact that no one has
managed to photo oh ember no but also it's no and it's
terminated by direct eye I was roasting you!
Why?
Wait!
It...
It's scared.
It doesn't like noise.
It says it doesn't like noise.
No, I didn't hear that noise.
No, no, no, no.
There's no noise.
Let's move.
Okay.
I'm following you.
Wait, does it like whistles?
Ugh!
Stop it!
Your boy!
Hahaha!
Where is he?
Oh, no, what is that?
Wait.
It's a locker.
What the fuck is making you out?
So whenever I found an enemy, whenever I encountered an
enemy, I can just hide inside the locker.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
Yeah, we can...
Your head is...
Wait, why is it right outside?
Get out.
I heard something.
Wait, what?
What do you hear?
Hello?
I heard I heard that I see I'm some- There's only one
locker, come over here!
Wait, wait, stop it!
No, no, no, no, no!
Wait!
Please, please, don't you!
Get out!
Please, Peter!
What a dialogue!
I don't like this collab.
What do you mean?
Are you having fun?
I'm having so much fun.
Oh, wait.
Wait, is this...
No, it's just more rooms.
It's just more back rooms.
Oh my god.
Where are we?
What is that?
Oh, we have to... It's a shadow.
Wait.
Oh, it's a horse!
It's a horse!
Yeah.
How do I...
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, okay.
Then what do we do with the horse?
I have no idea.
Wait.
Oh, it's a door!
Open the door!
Wait, what?
Did you see the silhouette?
But it's looking to R?
It seems that the clock...
Oh, wait, we need to find...
Wait, there's a...
It's a clock.
There is a clock.
Yeah.
We need to find clock hands.
Okay.
Okay, so there's a clock inside, so we need to find a clock
hand.
What is this?
So are we going to get inside this door?
Is it but is looking to the art?
What is wrong?
All right, we need to find clock hands.
Yeah.
All right.
So we're going to get in here, right?
Yeah, no, I already got in here.
And it's like, we're missing items.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, we're missing a clock hands.
Oh, cool.
Okay.
Guys, don't do that.
No, don't do that.
Hello?
Don't do that.
We're going to slowly and steady that we're not going to.
You're not gonna take any risk, you know?
Hello?
I need to mention you that you're playing with a fucking
beginner.
Wait a minute, I have never played this game before!
You've watched videos of this!
I haven't!
Okay, nothing here.
Dead end, dead end.
Okay.
Where do we go?
I'm already lost.
Did we come here before?
Me too.
Wait, did we come here?
I don't know where we are.
Where are we?
I don't know too.
I have no sense of the direction.
Come on.
You're good at...
Oh my god.
You're good at the direction.
Everyone knows about me is that I don't know where I am.
This is a dead end.
Have we been here?
She's... He's dead!
They're dead!
Okay.
Well, I don't think we're...
I don't think we're getting out of here.
How am I supposed to drink my almond milk?
I can't even...
How am I supposed to drink my almond milk inventory?
Thank
God I didn't...
I can't even open my inventory!
Move!
Okay.
Use.
Is my...
Who's that?
Is that you?
Oh my god!
That's you son!
Oh, we're so fucked.
We're so fucked.
You saw where are you going?
Yusun, where did you go?
Where did Yusun's shadow go?
Oh.
I'm so scared.
Oh, my God.
Where do I...
Let me go.
Yusun, look for the flashlight.
If you can hear me right now.
flashlight look find the flashlight and lead me to the
flashlight oh god i'm so you know what what if i just die
you know what come over what if i don't want to do this
alone Wait, wait, I just died.
You saw, did you find the flashlight?
Where is it?
Where's your shadow?
Where's the shadow?
Where's you saw shadow?
There's the shadow.
It's not me.
Okay, here, you see that?
You see this box?
Yeah?
Yeah, open that.
No, not that way.
Get out of the locker!
Be brave!
No!
Do your job!
You said open it!
You sacrificed your face!
Where are you?
Here, here, here, here, here, here, here, here.
You see this room?
Yeah?
What's the password?
Where are you?
Where did you go?
Oh, there's your shadow.
Okay.
Oh, I found more meds.
And almond water.
Okay.
But like, what's the code?
How do I...
What's the code?
Okay.
I can't... I can't switch...
How
do...
Wait.
How did I move?
How did I move that?
Okay.
1987.
Who opened the door?
Please.
Oh, it's a drag.
Okay, I figured it out.
It's not 1987.
It was not a swipe.
It was a drag.
I figured it out.
It's not.
1987 oh my god it was not the bite of 87 guys we figured it
out it was not the bite of 87 oh my god wait we'll close the
oh my fuck you we'll never figure this out okay but we close
the door me okay the drag of 87 i was panicking okay all
right all right we'll never figure out why this is why how
to get the right answer oh my god why would it be 1983 what
happened in 1983 i still don't know how we got 1987 from the
last quarter of us
I still don't know how we got that.
I still...
Oh, wait.
Maybe it is 1987.
And I just need to...
Wait, maybe it is.
I just need...
No, it's not.
It's not.
Oh, my God.
It's another bite.
Wait.
You saw...
Where did you go?
The bite of a...
We'll never figure it out.
Yusat, where are you?
Yusat?
Where'd they go?
Where'd they?
Yusat?
Please!
Why was I the one that died first?
Why couldn't it be me?
Oh my god.
Can you break the law?
Okay, if I could break the lock, I would have just thrown
the fucking box down right now We need lock pick master here
Who's that?
Oh, it's a stick figure guy It's him again Okay, someone
caught mad bad
Oh my god, okay, but what if I just died?
Look, we're still in the beginning.
It wouldn't matter if I just perished because we're still in
the beginning of the level Like like does it really matter?
Does it doesn't really matter Maybe he'll open
Okay, all right, you know what?
I'm gonna you know what I'm gonna do it I'm gonna it
wouldn't fucking matter.
I It wouldn't...
It wouldn't matter.
How does it matter?
You can revive.
How?
Where can I revive them?
Oh my god.
Where do I revive them?
My items?
I have just almond watered.
Oh my god.
I...
Oh no.
my almond water.
I'm so fucking scared.
I'm so scared.
You son, do you hear me?
You need to find the door of light.
Follow the light, you son.
Follow the light so you can come back.
I'll wait here in the locker.
What do you mean?
No.
Just find the light and I'll wait here.
Find the light And come back here
Alright Don't worry Yusun Find the light I can stay in the I
don't think I can stay in the locker Yusun
Yusun There's so many fucking lockers man Why is there maybe
this can be broken with something a fucking screwdriver?
No, the screwdrivers can't okay, maybe this is a bad idea to
play with two people I just realized Maybe that's a fucking
bad Who's that Who's that?
Oh my god What the fuck was that?
You can't hear you saw cuz they're dead
You can't hear them because the dead can't talk.
That's what it means.
You're not supposed to ghost people.
There's no ghosting allowed.
All right.
Why can't I just throw the fucking vase on the ground?
It's a fucking vase.
I need to finish reading this.
Oh, I need a hammer.
Oh.
What the fuck is a hammer?
Why can't I just throw in a fucking base?
It's made of glass!
This is so fucking dumb.
Oh hey, there's a head.
Oh my god, please.
You saw it.
Find the light!
Please!
Come, I swear to God, if you do not find the light right
now, I will let this monster here kill me.
I don't care what my fucking almond water.
I don't, okay, where the fuck's the monster?
Come over here.
I'm gonna, where the fuck is it?
I don't care anymore.
You saw would not find the light.
Something will come over and fucking rip me apart.
Oh, hey, there's more almond water that I can't use.
I can't even carry it.
I have too much albid water.
Something will fucking kill me.
There we go.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
You did this, you saw it.
Where is he?
Where's the stick figure guy?
Wait, what?
Hello?
Yeah, that's right.
Come on, kill me!
Hello?
Where is it?
What the fuck?
Get over here.
They're stuck in the wall!
What the fuck?
Oh my god, it can't even do the simple job!
Oh my god, it was stuck in the wall.
It was...
Get over here.
Okay, it's less scary when it's just smacking me in the
face.
to be it's a lot less scary follow the hell we both need to
fight are you kidding me it's like five okay well i gotta
find the door now
he's on you had five minutes to find the door All right.
I guess I'll find the door.
All right, where the fuck is the door?
Find the luminous door and revive.
You mean you had five minutes to find the fucking door and
you didn't find the fucking door?
What?
Okay.
Well, we found the fucking wheelchair.
And there's a teddy bear.
There's a radioactive door.
Holy shit.
What are all these items?
This is such a bad idea to play as a duo.
We should have been a full squad.
We shouldn't.
What?
I can't believe it.
And it was my idea to play this game, too.
Okay.
Can't you hear you suck?
I don't think you saw it's close to me.
I think you saw it's trying to find the door as well.
Wait.
I heard it.
It was shimmering.
You heard that?
I heard like a shimmering sound.
Where is it?
Gotta do the hard mode.
This is normal mode and we're fucking struggling.
I might even do easy mode after this.
At this.
right okay wait I found it wait wait oh oh wait this is it
you son get over here
this has to be it this has to be it wait what
this is it okay okay maybe I'm gonna wait a minute I'm gonna
wait a minute you You son has to show up.
You son.
Wait, that's you son.
Wait, what would that be you son?
That's me?
That's a...
This is the door.
This has to be the door.
Where's you son?
It's just me?
I have nine lives.
You saw you have no excuse I
I have nine Lies Oh my god We're restarting We're restarting
You so gay I'm not doing
this Fuck you Let me Like this I'm doing it Not easy.
I'm...
I'm doing it.
Lumao.
Fuck you.
Donkey.
What did I do?
Oh my god.
Lumao.
What the fuck do you mean?
You had for...
Why did you find the door?
I died and I can't do anything if I died.
Yes, you can.
You can find the door.
You find...
Yeah, I didn't know that.
I have to find the door.
Sorry about that.
You had to find...
You know what?
Now we know.
Now we know how to do that.
What about we just gonna figure it out?
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now we're better.
We're better people now.
All right.
Look at that.
Back here we go again.
Okay.
i'm gonna get i'm gonna get a ball come on you know all
right okay now we know what to do now we know yeah yeah now
we know we can we can rush this yeah yeah i'm gonna grab the
almond water give it to me you can have this you can have
the other one where does that uh the spray can okay yeah
yeah okay so i don't remember i don't remember where to go
i'm gonna follow you i'm gonna follow you no no no no let's
not get into somewhere dark you know maybe when you find a
Apparently there was a flashlight that we missed.
Yeah.
Oh, we can get a flashlight.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a flashlight.
Wait, you saw it?
Hello?
Oh, there you are.
Here you are.
Okay.
Okay, there's apparently like a flash.
Oh, that's a mirror.
Holy shit, actually.
Oh, my God.
Okay, there's like...
Wait, there's a TV.
Cannot turn on at this moment.
Did you hear that?
No.
Cannot turn on this.
I'm going to pretend I didn't.
if we don't acknowledge it it didn't happen okay okay
there's like apparently a flashlight somewhere oh they're in
the drawers oh oh the drawer is there a flashlight way no
that's anxiety you can have that I'll get it yeah okay we
have to find we have to wait there's door here oh it's just
two lockers it's just Oh,
what?
What?
Oh, they're not for hiding.
I can't even get on inside.
What the fuck?
There's like almond water.
There's shells.
I can't even get on in here.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Let's go.
Right.
Okay.
I heard a hit step.
No, no, no, no.
Okay, I think my favorite part was the fucking scream in the
distance
You saw find the door find the door you saw
Find the door I'll wait here Find the door You have nine
lives
I swear you'll be able to find the door it's so easy
it's so easy I mean I sacrificed them they're the ones that
die I saw red light okay oh there he already found the door
You so fell!
Yusun!
Oh wait, they don't have a radio.
Oh.
Yusun!
I'm alive.
I died.
You found the door!
Yeah, I died, but when I found the door, I revived.
Yeah, see, I told you!
That's all we need to do!
Oh, we were back here.
We went, we were here.
Because there was the mirror.
I need to experience the thing to, you know, educate myself.
Yeah, see?
It's all, it's a learning process.
You found the door!
Respect that.
Yeah, we did!
We're learning!
We learned!
Look at that!
See, now we know!
You need a key.
We need to find a red key.
Okay.
We need to find the red key.
Oh my- Oh, there's some more drawers!
Okay.
The hour is 1015.
Okay, more pills.
How is this level 2?
It's insane.
It's just a little bit.
level two do you hear that at my locker okay awesome awesome
what is this come on here here here here it's gonna kill you
not me anyway you know it's fine I'm just gonna run away you
can just die alone you know okay okay that way way it's okay
we'll die together okay yeah Awesome.
Oh, yeah, why don't we try here?
Where are we?
Here?
Yeah.
What did you go?
Oh, here, okay.
There we go.
Yeah, hello?
Hello?
Okay.
I'm so lost.
I... Me too.
Where are we?
It's like a maze here.
Yeah, it is the back rooms.
No, we've been here because the door is open.
Oh, wait, there's more.
There's more.
Oh, there's flashlight!
Oh, wait.
Is that flashlight?
Let's go!
god the one thing we've always we forgot to oh wait this was
the tutorial wait this is the first yeah this is the
tutorial we missed the flashlight in the tutorial oh my god
so bad we gotta carry me though you are a professional
streamer you can do this to me And we missed the flashlight
in the tutorial.
It's okay, now we have flashlight.
Yeah, okay, our mission before we end stream is to get out
of Venus.
Yeah, true.
We just need to...
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Is it okay?
Are we okay?
Oh, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
It's fine, it's fine, everything is fine.
Oh no!
I don't know!
I'm from monkey!
Oh my god!
He said, find the light!
Oh my god.
You son, did you come back?
Welcome back.
You son.
Help.
I died to- Come!
There's red light!
There's a monster!
I can die like this many times, please.
Okay, you son.
When you see the red light, there's a monster.
Okay, I got it.
When I see the red light, there's a monster.
I got it.
Okay, okay.
If you see red.
I heard the fucking sound.
What?
Oh, what's that?
That was a jump scare.
Oh, oh, oh, wait.
What's that?
What is a box?
What is it?
Oh, it's another light.
It's yours.
It's your flashlight.
You died here.
Oh, okay.
I got it.
Okay.
Why are we silly?
I feel like I've been here like 20 times.
I don't know where they go.
I'm gonna.
Okay.
Let's be brave.
For now.
I'm so brave.
Dead end.
where you died three times.
We keep coming back.
We keep coming back to where you died.
TV.
We've been here many times already.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
We have never progressed.
We don't progress anywhere.
We're always going back to the same place.
Shut up.
I'm focusing.
Wait, what is this box?
This is yours.
It's also yours.
Oh shit, I picked up some teeth and some ears.
Okay, here.
Oh my god, okay.
But there's nothing here.
It's okay, we don't have to mind about that.
Now, I really want to get out of my room.
I mean, get out of this room.
We need to find a new world.
We're back to the TV!
Why are we still always going back to the TV?
Where?
It's the same place.
This is the same room!
We died!
Same place!
Oh my god.
Never ending collab.
Are you ready for a long, long stream?
We're lost!
We keep going back to the same place!
Why did you go back to there?
Nah!
No, my god.
We need to figure out a new place to go!
Here!
Yeah, yes, I thought you actually- I thought you're
actually- I'm pretty sure we didn't come here.
I know the Minecraft streamer is good at the sense of
directions, right?
That is not true.
That is absolutely- No, we've been here!
Oh, the red key!
Yeah, this is the red key door!
Let's, you know, we gotta- we better just stick around here
and don't too go far from here.
Wait.
Okay, if you find a painting, look at it closer.
Okay.
Alright.
There must be a new place we haven't gone before.
There has to be one new place.
I refuse to believe that we're...
We found everything.
We need to break the cycle.
Wait, we haven't gone here, I think.
You saw it.
This way.
Okay.
Here?
I think so.
I don't think we've been here, right?
I bet so.
Yeah, this looks new.
There's no TV here.
Yeah.
There's no TV.
This is new.
Okay.
No, we've opened this door before.
Yeah, yeah.
This is the tutorial.
This is the beginning.
We're back in the beginning.
I'm focusing.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Here.
I spent 30 minutes on the tutorial.
You know what?
You shouldn't let me, you know, guide the way for you.
I shouldn't be guiding the way either.
Just as lost!
I'm just as lost as you!
I swear to God!
This is the TV room!
This is the fucking TV room!
It's the same room again!
We're back in the TV room!
We're back in the room!
Why do I keep going back to...
I really hate this game.
Wait, you said...
You said, come here!
Come here!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
This side, this side.
Here, here, here, here.
This has to be new, right?
I hope so.
I really hope so.
It's just a red key room.
I swear to God.
Okay.
Oh my God.
We're back in the beginning.
We're back.
We keep looping.
How do we get out of this loop?
Oh my God.
We must find our way out of this loop.
What is this loop?
We can never be a good team.
I'll tell you, Doki.
Oh my God.
No, no, no.
It's not us.
It's the game.
You're really bad, Commander.
I'm sorry.
Oh, yeah?
You do better.
No.
I found a new room.
It's dead bodies.
I'm, I'm, like, the beginner for most of the game.
I found a new room.
What is this?
At least I didn't find a TV room five times.
And so missing people were found in Paladin.
Some of your bodies were found in some anomalies.
Look for a VHS tape for more information.
Fish.
We need a VHS tape.
Okay.
Malcolm Fisher.
Oh!
Okay.
I- I- oh, we- we put like- I have like body parts on me.
So I think like we put like body parts on them.
Got it.
Like a- look at the corpses.
They hide a secret code.
Just pay attention to the blood.
What?
Pay attention to the blood.
Blood type, I guess.
I guess it's like heart.
Oh!
Wait!
Okay, I have...
Okay, the blood is...
The blood, okay.
Is there any blood on the leg?
I have a leg.
I mean, none of them are on the leg though.
I have foot and...
I have a foot and ear, but none of them are like...
None of them have like head or ears, God.
I have teeth too.
Hey, Ducky, look at it.
Insane Respect the dead body Okay Okay Okay Oh okay that's
hearing me Wait but how do we Do you have any idea for this?
The court We need to find We need to find a tape The tape
Yeah yeah Okay From the dead body right Yeah Don't touch the
smoke Because I think the smoke is like Dangerous Wait, we
need to find the tape and blood matches this to the keypad.
There's no blood here.
Alright, let's find a VH.
Let's go back.
We need to find a VH chest tape.
You want the almond milk?
Can we go up?
Here.
No, no, no.
There's almond water.
You should take it.
Okay.
It heals your HP.
Oh, okay.
I think I'm just going to heal my HP now.
Can I?
Use.
All right.
Look at the lock on the locker.
What do you mean?
Oh!
One, two, okay.
Wait, I figured this out!
I figured it out!
Two, three, okay.
Oh my god, I'm so fucking stupid.
Two, three, I did it.
Wow.
I did it.
I found a hammer.
We can break faces now.
Awesome.
Where are you, by the way?
Wait, where are you?
You son?
Hello?
Doki?
You son?
I'm gonna die.
Where are you?
I'm inside the locker now.
Get out the locker!
I just found two enemies already.
Like, I don't know.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I don't want to get out of my- Where are you?
Oh my god.
my god okay yeah i think they're gone it's okay
there's an enemy next to me why i can't even find you i hear
your voice you died no right there's people next to me come
over here i'm at the bodies
why is there red light leave
Leave!
What do you mean it's probably gone?
There's still red lights in front of me!
Okay.
I'm very anxious right now.
That's what meds are for.
I'm cured now.
I found the tape.
I found the tape?
Yeah, it was at the horse room.
Come to the...
Come to the body room!
Body room, okay.
Wherever you are!
Go back to the body room!
I don't know where you are I'm gonna be in the body room You
have a You still have your radio Yeah, I think so Oh god,
the radio is so fucking loud Okay, the body room, right?
Yeah, I'm in the body room Where was that?
What do you mean?
Where was that?
It's in the body room!
Are you?
I'm just...
I'm still in the body room.
I have so many items on me.
You can't let me die.
I have so many things on me.
Hey, hey.
Hello.
You son.
You son, where are you?
I'm trying to find where was the body room.
The body room.
I'm trying to find you.
We're up.
Okay, here.
Okay, look, look, look.
Go on here, aren't you?
why are you hiding inside the locker what there is there's a
person next to us no no it's gone oh it's got it's gone yeah
oh no no okay it's gone it's gone it's gone what do you mean
it's gone see red no it's there no it's gone you can't say
it's gone when i can see the color red okay now
It can't be like it's gone when there's red.
Okay, we need to find the TV.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait, what do I hear?
I heard something drinking.
Okay, okay, we need to find the TV room.
Okay.
We found it before 20 times.
We can do it again.
I know, right?
Yeah.
We found it!
Where?
Okay, no, there's an enemy in front of us.
It's over here.
Okay.
Yeah, there's an enemy there.
There's an enemy there.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
You know what?
I'm proud of us for it.
We can always find the TV room.
I know, right?
Yeah.
We can always find the TV room.
Okay, they're gone.
They're gone.
No, they're not.
I see red.
Really?
If it's red, there's enemies.
What do you mean?
Oh, my flashlight, it's not working anymore.
That's why.
Is it?
No, it is.
It's just when you're close to enemy, it doesn't work.
Wait, I just saw your stream, but okay.
But on my screen, it doesn't turn...
The light is not turning red.
Wait, what?
It's not turning red?
What's wrong with your screen?
Oh, there's a smoke.
Okay, we can't touch the smoke.
Why is it red again?
Why is it red?
We heard that.
Closer!
It's okay.
They won't be here.
It's gone.
Can I open the door?
They're gone.
Okay.
So where was the dead body?
Oh, it's a dog!
Wait, wait, look at the dog.
I see the dog.
Do you see the dog?
I didn't see.
I don't see the dog.
It's right there.
I'm looking at it.
Oh my god.
the door oh my god oh i'm hurt did you see the dog did you
see the dog i'm hurt look at that my screen is something
right now i told you i told you it was a dog i told you you
didn't but that's okay you didn't didn't believe me you're
the one that didn't believe me i said there was a dog let's
see if the dog's gone yeah they're gone they're gone okay we
saw the dog guys all right let's go to the tv let's go okay
put it in put it in oh finally okay interact okay use okay
all right what does it say
all right so there's nine bodies the team collected all the
bodies and piled them up on the empty room yeah that room we
didn't find that room again look not again
malcolm fisher where's the nominees no that yeah i i saw
that body Okay, Malcolm no-nose.
Malcolm no-nose.
Chat, remember this.
Lena.
No eye.
Okay, Lena no eye.
I have foot.
Chad.
Oh, I have teeth.
I have teeth on me.
Okay, we need to give Chad his teeth.
Mm-hmm.
And eyes for Lena.
And...
Those four are...
Okay OK, I have teeth already.
I have teeth already.
So let's go back to the body room.
Okay.
Okay, our mission, we just have to finish this room.
We just have to finish this level.
I like it.
The moment we finish this level, we win.
We win.
I don't know where to go.
I don't remember where was the body room.
Where was the fire?
Where was the body room?
Was it, like, in here?
You, son?
Yeah.
Where are you?
Here, here, here, here.
Where's here?
Come over here.
Here, here, here, here.
Okay.
All right, I think it was, like, in this corridor?
I hope so.
I think?
I can move properly.
Oh, my God.
I'm seriously lack of stamina.
Okay.
yeah i found i found it okay it was chad right wait there's
a red there's red this is lena okay we need to find chad
okay we need to find chad chad is teeth marco selene frank
robber Okay, I found Chad.
The last one.
I just put it here?
Can I do it?
Okay, I got teeth.
Alright.
We need...
We need to find...
An eye and a nose.
Okay.
How do we find a...
Okay, we just gotta look.
Alright.
Okay.
Did you go this way yet?
nope I guess all right we didn't do we go here yet no I
don't think so that's just a locker it's just a normal
locker not my locker you know but it could be a trap where
the fuck is the nose wait there's red here who's over there
though I don't know where we haven't gone want me to go
there I don't know I'm so lost where do we not go i can
never tell i heard the sound oh what the night footsteps i'm
just gonna give myself a ball i'm just gonna go
no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
i thought they're not
Was that my fault?
They're not fast enough for the locker?
Why was that my fault?
What do you mean?
How could I?
Whoever gets the locker first win.
They could have picked their own locker.
They could have found their locker.
I did not abandon you some I saw a locker and I went for it
look I have the no I have the the the ear and the legs this
is important I have the ears and the leg I can't die
I can't exactly don't need to outrun the monster gotta be
faster than the other person
i just need to be faster exactly that was that was horrible
what do you mean i found the locker that was horrible i said
oh shit i'm scared i'm like anxious now maybe we can wait do
we go here come here here here oh hey we never been here we
haven't been here Where did you go?
What is that?
Wait, I have hammer.
I have the hammer.
Nice.
I have screwdriver, by the way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, I don't have the hammer.
Do you have the hammer?
I don't have it, actually.
Really?
Wait, let me check my email.
You have it?
I didn't pick it up.
It's...
No, I don't have it.
Wait, wait, I do.
I do.
I'm dumb.
How do I...
It puts I...
Wait, one.
Okay.
How do I...
How do I bring my hammer out?
Swing it!
What do I...
I can't...
It won't let me bring my hammer out!
I'm scrolling!
Wait you have to equip it!
Equip it!
I did!
Why?
Okay.
Gaming it or I don't know.
Okay, you...
You do...
Okay, you're so good.
You picked up the hammer.
Okay, okay.
Let me try that.
dote.
Equip...
That's right.
equip okay how do i use that yeah oh yeah yeah how do you
use it yeah how do we use it yeah wait interact uh maybe you
can break something wait yeah yeah how do you use it you saw
it oh wait wait press e then i then scroll wheel
What did you say?
Plus E, I, and then scroll wheel.
So I have to equip first, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
E, yeah.
I, yeah.
Scroll.
Yeah.
No, it's not.
It's not working.
All right.
See, I told you it wasn't easy.
Okay, fine, fine, fine.
I'll figure it out.
E, I.
Oh, my God.
I'm so...
I figured it out.
I'm so proud of ourself.
Dookie, dookie, dookie, dookie, dookie.
Wait, wait, did you hide inside the locker?
Dookie, dookie, dookie.
I'm safe.
Okay, I'm safe.
Okay, where are you?
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm just breaking everything right now.
Is this?
I found the red key!
No, he's...
What's that?
What?
It's me.
Why were you screaming?
I'm in front of you.
You don't see me?
I see you, but why were you screaming?
No, I'm happy.
I'm happy.
Oh, you're happy.
Okay.
I thought something happened.
I was like, there's something...
There's a dog.
You saw where are you?
No, you saw you okay.
You're inside the locker?
Okay, it's gone.
It's gone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We watched it.
Yeah, yeah, we did it.
We did it.
We're a team.
Ah!
No!
It's fine, it's fine!
It's not fine, he's in front of me!
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine!
I need to take that sugar.
Oh no, it is!
Stop,
run!
Run!
Find a locker!
Are you okay?
are you so are you okay it's gone oh my god okay okay we're
so good at this game use okay i need i need to drink my
almond water okay where are you where did you go i'm here
okay okay i'm gonna break some more bases um more violence
break everything nice okay i have the red key we got oh do
you want the anxiety pills do you need some i need it yeah
here there's some more.
I ran out of my anxiety pill.
Oh my God.
The dog left.
Is there anything else?
There's more anxiety pills here.
I need it.
Yeah.
Leave us alone!
We just wanted to eat our pills.
What the dog doing?
Leave us alone!
I'm alive, alive!
Is the dog still there?
No!
Just do it!
If the dog's there, we're gonna get out of the- Woo!
Woo!
It's there!
You see that?
It's just right there!
I don't have enough almond water!
there you see that I do I'm looking at it right now they're
looking at me right now they're staring at me why did you do
that to me why why oh the water fucking die what was that
what did you do that explanation what do you mean I didn't
do anything I'm just trying I'm about to fucking die.
I'm about to fucking die.
What the fuck?
Stay there.
Oh my god.
Monster magnet.
Shut up, chat.
Is there anything else in the vases?
Get out of the way!
I can!
I just...
But I want to find... I want to know if there's anything
else...
My sight!
Is there anything else in the vases?
That's the only reason why I'm breaking them!
Why is he still there?
Leave!
The dog fucking loved me!
me so bad oh my god oh my god okay but there's one more vase
though oh it's just the key well i did not need to break
that many vases okay is he gone they're gone they're gone
nice nice okay okay i need to drink my almond water again
okay we can leave now we have the key Awesome.
Awesome.
I'm happy that we're out.
Okay, come here.
Oh, it's still here!
Leave!
Leave me alone!
What the fuck?
He's still here!
No, it's gone!
No, he's literally still here!
I'm looking at him!
Don't worry.
No, no, get out.
You know.
I did just the freaking the scream from I like how I heard
the scream from the distance
it's like oh no no it's not he's not here Wow!
Oh my god.
Is it...
Is it gone now?
Is the doggo gone?
My helmet water.
I love my helmet water.
You said?
Come, he's gone.
He's gone for real.
Yusun.
I can't do it.
Yusun, come over here.
Get out of the room!
Get out of the
room!
Leave us alone!
Oh my god.
Leave!
For the love of God!
I can't leave!
Just leave!
We just wanted we just want to finish this level this is all
we want just a fucking Leave us alone!
Oh my god!
I'm just here forever!
Where are you?
You suck!
Get out of the room!
Oh my god!
Why is it still here?
Oh my god.
Yusar, I'm gonna leave the room.
Yusar.
Yusar, run!
Run to me!
Yusar, run to me!
Run to the base!
Run out of the vases Get out of the vase room Oh my god,
dog, no, yeah, no
What the hell is this?
Dog
Dog Fuck out of here Oh my god, I can't see I can see any
shit.
Oh my god Anxiety pill?
Oh my god, I use all of my almond water.
That's insane.
Oh my god.
Save her.
Please.
Don't get it.
Oh yeah, I see you.
I see you.
Get out of the base room!
Just leave that room!
Oh, this is just...
Get out of the base room!
You saw it.
I want to leave.
I want to leave that.
Get out.
Get out?
To where?
Get out of the base room.
Leave the base room.
Leave that room.
I swear.
Wait, I heard this.
Wait.
I heard something.
Base room.
What are you talking about?
Just leave that room!
Get out of that room!
Get out of the area!
Please!
Wait!
Bucky, where are you?
Okay, I'm in the chest box right now.
I'm in the chest.
Okay, we're out.
We're out!
We did it!
You suck!
Turn around!
I'm here!
Okay, we don't have to use the radio.
We did it!
out of the room that's all i wanted i just wanted to leave
that room
here there's more anxiety i found a hand and i found alman
water oh my god we're finally out of the room and we did it
we we did it we're out of their room this game is hard yo
Yeah, why did everybody love to play this game?
Oh my god.
It's a fucking hard.
You saw it.
I just need you to know we're on easy mode.
No!
We're on...
This is easy mode.
We spent almost an hour to...
Oh!
Read note.
Radiation room.
There's a locked door.
So, holy...
We don't have the...
We don't have anything to protect ourselves.
We need the protection suits.
Yeah, yeah.
Come over here.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Close.
This is a tutorial and it's easy.
Radiation.
I didn't want to tell you until now.
We've been on easy this entire time.
I don't believe.
We are 100% on easy.
Okay, we need to figure out how to find the door.
Did you see the red light?
No, I didn't see that.
I think there's the bug on my, you know, game screen.
Here's the red light.
No.
It's not there.
It's fine.
Okay.
Okay, here we're good.
We're good.
We need to find the red door.
Okay, we're back in the body's room.
This is not the door room.
But I remember, like, um...
The red door is just...
Just, you know, we...
It's supposed to be around here, I mean.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'll follow you.
You saw, you find it.
You're so good at finding the door.
No.
I am really good at, like, dodging dogs.
But you found the door.
You found the door, like, three times before.
Oh, there's...
we do that i don't know following you how did we do that i
don't remember what i don't here no here is it is it here i
don't i don't know i'm just following you no this is the
tutorial we're back
i saw i also think you're really good at finding the
tutorial here here here here here here here here you know
why can i can i make some excuse i think there is the bug of
my game yeah wait i can i can spray paint and oh my god wait
wait how do i spray paint what is it for oh my god wait wait
wait how do i spray paint how do i use this wait look look i
can okay oh my god yeah what is it for for what i can use
this to tell us where to go oh my god wait wait the change
image okay that's awesome okay how do i how do i use the
spray paint how do i do this beware exit oh look at that
look at that look at this yeah how do yeah yeah yeah left
click oh my god we should have done this why did we do this
what was it so hard oh my god why were we so stupid why were
we so stupid we didn't know how to play this game okay all
right Oh my god.
Okay.
We figured out how to use this.
The moment we find the door.
What?
Can we display this hallway just in case, you know?
Yeah.
How do I, how did I do that?
I don't know.
You're the one that did it.
Just to make sure.
Yeah.
Why do we need to spray this hallway?
What is this hallway going to be?
Just to make sure that we're not getting lost again.
Okay.
But they don't have, why are they all ones?
I don't know.
wait it's not here this wasn't it this is what we figured
out how to use the spray paint though so i'm painting once
you know you can change the picture no i just want to make
sure we've been here already you know
everything is just one
Oh my god.
You son.
Is he son dead?
I don't know, guys.
Do you think you son's okay?
Guys.
Do you think they're okay, guys?
I can't tell.
Oh my god.
you said you said find the door find the the white
look I'm I'm not gonna say that is my fault all I'm saying
is that the locker was right there and either of us could
have got it.
It was a 50-50 in getting the door.
It's not my fault.
Not, you know, that was your fault.
That was your fault.
Are you okay?
How's it my fault?
No.
No?
I'm not okay.
How is that my fault?
You did it.
You were the one that didn't get the door, the locker.
I died four times already in this round, you know?
Yeah!
That's...
That sucks.
But that's not my fault.
I don't think it's this way.
I think...
I think it's, like, somewhere in one of these corridors.
Maybe this one?
Okay.
No, this is the body one.
This is the body.
Maybe this one?
He's, uh...
Where'd you go?
This one?
this one this one wait this is the one where you spray
painted one so it's definitely not this it's not here is it
here no this is it's a tv we keep going to the tv wow you're
memorizing the map nice okay there's red there's red light
there's red light there's red light you son there's red
light there's red light there's red light there's red light
i really hate it you know i think
oh no no no no no no i see him i see him he's like walking
over it's gone it's fine it's fine oh you see that you see
that this one here yeah do you see it oh wait i'm getting
crazy looking at it don't look at it no don't look at it by
the way there's like oh it's gone it's gone okay it's gone
it's gone yeah yeah yeah i was like you see that wait never
don't be like no i don't think i see it wait i heard
something instead there's a horse room wait did you finish
the horse yeah we finished the horse we did we did yeah yeah
in this room we got the screwdriver wait oh wait i found it
wait i got a nose yeah there's a nose do you need albin
water there's albin water right here freeze freeze freeze
don't worry yeah there's albin water Oh my god, we got the
nose.
Okay.
All right, we're figuring it out.
I didn't know that that was a nose.
I thought that was something else, to be honest.
Okay, we were here before.
I remember this.
Okay.
Where the fuck is the red door?
I don't remember.
We found it so many times.
Here.
Okay, here.
No, this is the dog room.
We don't need to go back to the dog.
Oh, yo.
That's the dog room.
Okay.
We don't have the go-to-the-clock.
We don't have the clock arms, though, guys.
I don't have the arms for the clock.
Okay, we have the nose.
Where the fuck?
All right, chat.
Do you guys remember where the red door is?
It gets to you.
Chat, wait, wait.
I can't breathe.
Oh, look, don't, look, don't, look, look.
There's a face in there.
There is a face in there.
No, I don't see that.
I don't see that.
He's still there.
Don't look at it.
Are we gonna go insane if we look at their face?
Yeah, yeah.
If we look at the face, we go crazy.
Okay, it's gone.
It's gone.
Okay.
I'm pretty sure I found the body room.
Guys, who has no nose?
Who has no nose?
Eyes.
eyes i bet you know we're gonna use the red key and open the
door and there's gonna be the eyes yeah i'm pretty sure
right i think so it has to because our next one is the is
the key we just we just don't know where this one is yeah we
can't find this guy this guy door i got it i got Welcome.
Alright.
Hey.
Okay.
Wait, wait.
Mark this, mark this area.
We should mark this area to remember there.
Can you change the picture.
And write change the picture to something?
Oh this.
They cannot all be ones.
You saw me.
It could be yeah.
Change picture.
Change power.
Wait, wait.
They can all be ones.
Okay.
That's still a one, but okay that's.
How about that?
I guess so.
That's good enough, right?
That's good enough, yeah.
That works, that works.
It's not a nose, that's for sure.
I'm trying to like figure out.
We know that we've been there.
Yeah, yeah, at least we know that's the fucking area.
Where the fuck is the door?
We need something.
We need someone who's actually genius to play this game.
We need to find the door!
Where is the door?
Where?
Where is the?
I'm at the tutorial.
Oh my god.
Just follow me, just follow me.
Just follow me.
I trust you.
Okay.
It's gonna work.
Yeah.
Alright.
I'm running out of my stamina.
I'm trusting you right now.
It's red.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's here.
We did it!
Oh my god.
I knew I could trust you.
I knew I just told you.
You always know where the door is.
We should have followed you.
I should have believed myself.
You should have believed yourself.
Okay, they said, look at the painting.
There might be a code.
They said the painting has a code inside.
How do we look?
I don't know.
How do we...
How?
What the...
They're like, the painting has a code.
Oh.
I don't see any numbers here.
I don't see anything.
Did you just...
Wait, wait, I see it!
I see it!
What?
Come here, come here, come here!
Look at this!
Yeah, I'm looking at it.
You not see it?
Like, this angle.
It's like red.
This angle.
I don't see that.
You don't see it?
Wait!
Yeah, you see it?
Oh!
Okay, I see...
What does it say?
Is that an A?
What is this?
Is it...
Is it L?
What is that?
L.
A.
Okay.
L-A.
R.
M.
What does that spell?
I don't know.
I don't know that spells me either.
Don't worry, chat will know.
Wait, what is that?
I got fingers.
Lumau.
Lumau?
Is it this?
Guys, is it Lumau?
guys is it la mao oh it's moral okay okay i figured it out
it's moral okay guys thank you it's la mao thank you oh my
god i still don't know how 1987 was the answer and i'll
never know
is l l oh here it is nice whoa oh yeah get the almond water
i got i can't take it anymore i got too much water oh you
got too much water okay i got it yeah i got a i got a few
fuses and moon jelly only jelly what the do i do with the
fuses in the fuse box okay wait but like what do we Where do
we go next?
I feel like we did so many things.
What else are we missing?
Chat.
I don't know anymore.
I don't know what to do anymore.
Where was the fuse room?
There was a fuse room?
There was, was there?
I don't know.
I don't think I've ever seen the fuse room.
I've never seen it before.
So I think we don't have to go old.
We don't have to come back here anymore, isn't it?
I don't know.
what i don't think you know what what about we just gonna
stick in that room first but like but like we're what we're
but like what do we do we need and i we need to find clock
hands but where's where the fuck are the clock hands we're
gonna figure it out later it's at one okay oh we still need
the body parts now we need to figure out all the all the
okay wait wait wait wait where was the red room again i just
want to make sure to wait use the spray can to you know here
this is it this is it okay you see there's a monster here oh
my god no no no no are you
okay chat yeah i'm still alive what do we chat okay okay I
want to make sure we didn't miss anything.
I'm going to go back in.
Yeah.
I want to be sure we didn't miss anything in this room
because I don't want to come back here.
And this way is pretty simple.
I mean, these are just lockers.
It's just a locker.
Okay.
There's a cat here.
Hello, little kitty.
Yeah, there's nothing here.
There's nothing in the drawers, too.
All right, we didn't miss anything.
Nice.
Wait.
Yeah?
What is that?
Is that a porn?
No, it's a cat.
It's a pussy.
Pussy.
Pussy in my pussy.
My pussy in bio.
Okay.
All right.
We got, what do we do next chat?
We, we don't know where the clock hands are.
What, what's in your inventory?
Yisa, do you have any clock hands?
What's in your inventory?
Wait, let me check.
No, I have screwdriver.
uh splicam i have moly jelly okay i have that too yeah i
have all that yeah we don't i don't know where else to go i
feel like we went so wait okay alpha the dog's here the dog
what if i just call me the dogs to our right the dogs there
no dead end dead end dead end the dogs here i saw the dog i
saw the dog dog dog dog dog dog dog dog dog dog dog dog dog
dog dog dog dog i saw the dog the dog we're back in the
tutorial we're always back in the tutorial seriously okay
okay follow me i'm just gonna try my wild i'm just gonna try
my six cents we'll never get out of the tutorial running out
of pills i'm running out of here what about here oh my god
where will we leave the tutorial okay it's a radiation room
here again yeah but we can't go to the radiation room
because we'll get radiated okay let me mark it let me mark
the radiation room just in case how do we know it's the
radiation room i mean you know it'll equip use Okay, change
color.
Oh, we can find the vase room.
Remember the vase room?
Why is the dog always here?
Oh, my God.
Leave us alone.
This.
Please, I don't have a lot of Alvin water.
I just want to get out of tutorial why is the tutorial so
high
all right we figured this out I'm in the I'm in the chest
room chest room I found the clock hands
Okay, guys, what is the numbers?
We don't need to figure that we can do this together.
Yes, we don't need the clue.
Get us out of tutorial.
Guys, we don't need the clue.
We don't need to actually solve this.
Just hand me the numbers right now.
It can't be 1015.
That's the fucking clock.
It can't.
I told you I knew it was at 1015.
No way, it's 1987.
It's again.
Oh my god.
Yeah?
Okay, in the chest room, right?
Found you.
There's red.
There's red outside.
You should come in.
I see red light.
We're trying to figure out the passcode for this.
It's not 1980.
Everyone's like, it's 1987.
I swear to God, it's not.
1987 I swear the guy I knew it I fucking knew it I fucking
knew it was a 1987 okay I found the clock out so you
remember where the horse is yeah okay okay here
here here wait why is my flash though I cut it off she
around here I did I'm frowning.
Are you...
Are you sure?
I don't think that's...
I don't think that's where the...
No, it's not here.
It's not here.
I don't think...
I don't think that's... I think it's back here.
I'm pretty sure.
I found it.
I knew it.
I...
Yeah.
So I don't think you knew the way.
I don't think you knew the way.
No, you were not correct.
That was...
That was absolutely not.
No, you're not correct.
There was no way.
I was halfway correct.
No, you were not Come on you can you can you can solve this
game alone.
I swear to God.
How do we how do we how do we do the clock?
How do we I'm trying Oh, it's back here.
Wait, what?
Oh, back.
Okay.
Okay, back.
Where was it?
Oh, okay.
Is it 10?
It's 10.
Yeah, yeah.
Is it on 10?
It's on 10.
Okay, is this on 5?
Let me know when it's on 5.
Okay, so the short one is on 10, and the long one is on 5
right now.
Oh, okay.
Is the long one on 10 yet?
Wait, no, no, wait, wait.
Long one's on 5, right?
The long one's on them 5, yeah.
Yeah, okay.
Is this on 10?
No, seven.
Ten?
Five.
Three, two.
Oh my god, where the fuck is?
Just go.
Almost there.
Twelve, eleven, ten.
Now ten.
Okay, this is short.
Okay, this is on fifteen.
The short one, right?
I need long one.
Long, long, long.
Eleven.
I need fifteen.
I heard something.
Twelve.
I'm hearing something.
It's the dog.
Shh.
Two, three, three, two, one.
Four, eleven.
Ten, nine.
Where the fuck is fifteen?
Seven.
Wait, fifteen, three.
You gotta put it on three.
Three, three.
Okay.
Yeah.
Two, one.
Okay.
One, two, three.
There we go.
Oh, my God.
No, we're asking such a stupid question.
No, wait, that's the shorthand.
The long hat has to be on 10 and the long hat has to be on
3.
Oh, the long one has to be on 3.
The K, is this on 10?
Is this on 10?
The short one is on 2 right now.
Okay, I need the short one to be on 10.
I I I'm so stupid Okay now we're so Now we gotta move the
long arm to Oh my god we're both so dumb One Two Three There
we go We did it Yay What the fuck You're pretty bad at
listening What do you mean?
Okay three seven zero eight Okay we gotta go back to the The
dog room.
3-7-0-8.
Oh my god.
The dog room here, right?
Here?
It's supposed to be here.
Right?
Here, yeah, this way, this way.
Oh my god.
We're so...
Oh!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh
Oh You Where are you?
Where are you?
I used up everything Where are you now?
Oh I'm I'm freaking out I'm freaking out Are you fucking-
everything is trying to kill me?
Everything is trying to kill me.
Leave me The fuck alone!
oh is it gone now is it gone now
guys i have all the good i have all the stuff right now i
can't die if i die This is important.
I have a lot of this stuff right now.
Okay, I need to make sure I don't die I need to make sure
Are you okay?
Are you alive?
You're alive.
Okay, let's go to the let's go to the dog room This game's
not okay for you.
We're fine.
Oh my god.
Okay, okay.
We gotta run to the dog room 3708 Okay, we're here Okay,
three seven.
I got this three seven
Zero eight Huh?
Oh, okay.
It just didn't register.
Oh my god.
We got pliers.
What the fuck are the pliers?
What are the pliers for?
Progress!
We got progress.
But what is it for though?
What is this for?
I have no idea.
Oh, the first, first, first!
Open!
Oh, no, no, no!
You closed the door.
Why did you close the door on yourself?
Did I do that all by myself?
I thought you were worse than me.
Yeah, no!
You closed it yourself!
It's the whole time just all by my own.
Oh my god.
I'm just watching you close the door on yourself.
What the fuck?
Wait, what, what, what are we missing?
Like an eye.
We're missing an eye.
We need to find, yeah, we're missing eyes.
Who do I use the pliers for though?
I don't know.
Okay, we don't have to come back here ever again.
We're done here.
Oh my god.
Chat, help.
What are we missing?
Chad please what where do we need to go we went through
everything Chad did we go through all that where were you
heading on my left there's no there's smiley face near us oh
my god that's the red door yes no that's the body parts
these are body parts we don't need to be here
mirror room wait they said go to the mirror room we have to
go to the mirror room I forgot yeah yeah yeah okay I believe
in you you son you can find the mirror room the mirror room
that's like the room the one room we've always find believe
my sense I believe in you yeah that is the what what's not
there that's the dog room that's the dog room
Damn.
Well, we're here.
No, that's the tutorial.
Here.
Come here.
Oh, wait.
It's near the tutorial room.
Because I know it's near the tutorial room.
That's the one room we're really good at.
Wow.
Whoa.
Here.
Is that it?
Smiley face!
Smiley!
Okay.
It's not here.
That's the dog room again.
We're back in the dog room.
We're back in the dog.
Where the fuck is the mirror room?
Okay.
Tutorial.
This is tutorial.
I remember.
They said this is tutorial.
We're literally at the tutorial again.
Where is it?
Okay.
Why are we so lost?
For real.
Guys.
Okay, follow me.
Follow me.
100%.
If there were two more people, we would have definitely
solved this a lot faster.
Here.
It's a tutorial.
It's the elevator.
Look for the ones.
Here.
You son?
Where are you?
Scared!
Where is I'm at the mirror room!
Come here!
Where are you?
I'm back in the tutorial!
Come to me!
There was a monster!
I'm at the beginning!
oh my god where are you i'm at the beginning find the ones
you son find your ones you son you son you son hello hello
you son you son where are you i'm at the ones i'm at the
ones i i need my taxi come to the mirror room i don't know
what that mirror room is i'm just believe this just believe
yourself i don't believe in myself i don't believe in myself
pick me up come on uber you know what now is the time now is
your time to be independent i don't want to be independent
no you gotta have to independent i don't want to be
independent It's too scary!
How dare you, you can spoil it like this!
Oh, I'll tell you.
I'm here.
Oh, let's go.
I did it.
Are you proud of me?
Okay, we're at the mirror room, guys.
What do we do at the mirror room?
What do we do?
We're at the mirror room.
Yeah, what do we do?
a room.
Smashy, smashy time?
How do I smash it?
Go through the Miller.
No, we can't.
Wait, how about the hammer?
I don't know.
I can't get the hammer.
No, it's not the hammer.
It's not.
Smash.
It says smash.
You can?
Where?
How?
I don't know.
I'm pretty sure.
Smash the Miller.
How do you smash it?
Oh, body parts first but where's the eye we can't find the
eye how do we find the eye we don't know where the eye is we
don't know where the eye i'm just gonna make sure to mark
the you know yeah use okay so okay where the fuck's the eye
okay wait what the fuck that's the wrong i shouldn't be
using i shouldn't be using this image what the oh my oh i
hate that oh my I fucking...
Do you remember that last vase we never smashed?
That had the eye in it.
I can't believe it.
Okay, we gotta find the vases again.
The dog room.
I can't believe it.
I can't fucking believe.
Oh, wait.
Did you mark it to tell us that that's the eye?
This is the mirror room?
I think that was the...
That's not the good place to mark.
Okay, here.
Mirror room.
Okay, mirror room.
Okay.
all right mirror room okay it's pretty obvious now i can't
now we know where the mirror is i can't believe the last
base was where the fucking eye is no this is not where the
vases is it's like back here we need to find the you
remember the horse room we need to get there okay yeah yeah
yeah Wait, where did you go?
You son?
Here?
You son, where are you?
Let me go over here.
What about here?
What's room here?
Here?
Nope.
No, no, no, no.
It's not here.
No, no, it's here.
It's here.
This is the exit.
And now we need to figure out where the dog room is.
We need to figure out where the fuck is the dog room.
Okay.
we're at the tutorial we're at the tutorial that's the
tutorial i think it's here right no that's the dead end i
remember the dock room was somewhere i mean not the dock
room though i mean the the horse room was just near around
the tutorial this is the tutorial this is the elevator here
no this is the elevator elevator okay follow me follow me
again okay okay i'm gonna use my believe in here no it's
this way you're here six cents i trust your six cents i'm
not smart enough to play okay this is the mirror room this
is the mirror i'm not smart enough to play this game
seriously wait why was this red why do we mark this red red
door all right yeah the door the leather door okay yeah no
or was it the no this is the door yeah yeah yeah this is
this this is it wait why is it red okay this is it yeah yeah
yeah and then we go straight down okay oh my god he's right
there i heard something no he's right in front of us he's
like in the walls
all right this is it i swear the god there was no there was
no fucking eye you liars you fuckers lie to me there was no
eye you fuckers where the fuck is the eye oh my god it was
not the last base I fucking knew it!
Then where is it?
Where's the last...
Where's the last body?
Oh my god.
How many dead bodies?
How many dead bodies are there?
I trusted you, chat!
Locker with shells, but we opened every locker.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, wait, you died.
Wait, you died?
I died.
You died?
Sorry, I stole your screwdriver.
I didn't realize you...
Yeah, I have screwdriver.
Oh, I didn't realize you died.
Wait, did we open the TV drawers already?
The radioactive room?
That's where the eye is?
But we have no protection suits.
Yeah, we don't have any protection suits.
can we just walk into without the protection room can we
just walk through but they're like okay there's a locked
door that only will open the radiation of the room is on low
it's achieved this is a class d it won't limit it but it
will decrease the radiation don't go in there the suits no
wait wait you can steal it yeah maybe you can interact this
guy i don't know how do we take his suit Oh, everybody was
like, don't go through.
Don't go through the room.
They're like, don't do it.
Okay, thank you.
Yeah, we won't.
We won't go.
Thank you.
Don't trust.
Where's the Ithin?
I swear to God.
Wait, screwdriver?
Oh, no, I don't have the screwdriver.
No, I haven't.
I have it.
I took it.
Okay.
All right.
oh my god okay we need to figure out we need to figure out
where the fuck is the eye where is the protection suit where
is it where is it i don't i don't know where it is it's
enter check in that room take his eye you guys are pretty
random oh my god we're never gonna progress i thought I
thought you guys are backseating us.
Oh, it's red.
Why is it red?
I know.
Why is there a sand in me?
From the miller.
Where is it?
No, I don't believe that.
It's in the room.
What do you mean?
I looked at all the lockers.
What in the wall?
Did we miss?
There is a locker next to it.
Wait, there's a locker next to it.
the red door.
Did we miss out the eye?
Okay, okay, okay.
The red room drawer.
Find us the red room.
Oh my god.
Find the red room.
The red door.
It's not there.
Where are you going?
Oh, it's apparently random.
It's...
Okay, it's random and they say it's usually in the locker.
It's in the locker or drawer.
We're missing a drawer.
Okay.
all right we might die here because it's there's a red light
but i don't know where the where the monster is right now oh
my god we need to find yeah it's okay okay we need to find
the red door the red door okay i believe in you okay just
follow me it's okay i'll be responsible this is the dog room
i thought the the red room is near the dog room it's not I
know it's not here it's not there it's a it's not here this
is the dog because this is why are we back at the dogroom
we're never Are you leaving?
No.
Go back.
Hey, Scott.
I see God.
Let me check.
It's not.
Okay.
We live in the locker.
Live in the locker.
Okay, it's gone, it's gone, it's gone.
It's a guide?
It's gone.
We gotta find the eye!
You son!
Is it still red?
Just red, just red, just red.
Just red!
Oh, no!
Why the fuck let us...
Free us, please!
I just want to finish the tutorial!
Why is this the hardest level ever?
What is wrong with this game?
I have my last anxiety pill!
You son, where are you?
son you son okay this is the the body room wait there's more
anxiety pills let's go if i close my eyes
oh my god i lost you son where are you You son!
What if I just die?
You know what?
What if I just die and find the fu- I swear to god.
I swear- I think the best thing I can do right now is I die
and I find the eye.
Oh, I found the fucking- I found the red door.
Just kill me.
I found the red door.
Just kill- just kill me.
End this!
There's no eye here anyway!
Okay.
all right we got we can fight we're gonna find the eye i
swear i'm gonna find the fucking eye i'm gonna find the eye
while i'm dead i'm gonna find the eye while i'm dead it's
the only way it's the only way awesome it's the only way
okay you're there okay i see a shadow luck i see there's no
timer i'm gonna find the eye i'm gonna find the eye while
i'm dead
i can't see items when i'm dead then what are you kidding me
i can't even see items when i'm dead i oh my god
oh my god this is a hell
No!
I can't find items while I'm dead.
Okay.
Well, I learned.
Wait.
Wait, where's the mirror room?
Did we check the TV fucking drawers?
I swear to fucking God, if we never, like, looked into
the...
Looked into the drawers in the TV mirror room, I swear to
fucking God.
I would be so mad.
I would be so fucking mad.
I...
I don't know where the T...
Okay.
I swear to God.
Okay, all the drawers are open.
All right, all the drawers are open.
Thank fucking God.
I'm trying to...
Did we ever open this?
I swear to God, did we ever open this?
I swear...
Oh my God.
Oh.
Oh my fucking God.
Okay, yes I did.
All right, I'm back at the tutorial.
I know, I need a revive, but I need to figure out where the
fuck am I first.
Okay, this is the revive room.
Where's the...
This is the mirror room.
I keep going back to the mirror room.
This is the red room.
Okay.
Red room is here.
Okay, red room is here.
I swear.
Where is it?
I'm slowly...
I'm going crazy right now.
Where the...
Okay.
Radiation room.
I'm going to check the radiation.
to know what the fuck is in the radiation room i'm gonna
make sure i've okay those are just lockers okay i was gonna
be like i swear i swear to fucking god if there was like
nothing did we ever open the drawers in the clock room did
we oh my god did we guys did we oh yes oh thank god okay i
just needed to know that all right what was in this room it
was a gas mask a bucket wait i couldn't look at items while
dead what the fuck did you guys mean when you said i caught
it the fuck are these
okay radiation room so many doors oh my god there's like
crutches there's a fucking teddy bear How do I get out of
here?
How do I?
How do I get out of here?
Oh, those are not items.
You mean they're not items?
They just exist?
I don't know how to get out of here now.
Must be.
Where am I?
Okay, here it is.
Alright, we're gonna find the...
We're gonna get out of here.
Those items don't count that as a puzzle.
The moment we find the eyeball and finish the fucking
body...
parts i'm where this it's over this oh my god oh where's the
door it does revive me okay how do i get revived i don't get
revived where is it where's the heartbeat
i hear the heartbeat but where where is it okay oh oh okay
follow the trail follow the light trail oh i'm here all
right i'm back i'm back why oh my god i'm back don't worry
when you want to revive you're gonna follow the light yeah
yeah i was trying to i was trying to see with lock a locker
that like we didn't open i was trying to find a locker we
already did the red door though it's not the red door this
one's that door yeah but like we have to the horse room
right we opened all of these it's like in a drawer the eye
is in a drawer or a locker that we didn't open but we opened
everything we opened everything where okay tv room tv room
lockers body room a tiny offshoot near their vase room what
a tiny offshoot near the vase suit which has a drawer with
the eyes the vase room has two spots the eye can be okay we
need to think okay we we checked the tv room and the tv room
lockers right we did all that let's go to the lottery open
all the drawers there we've opened the body room okay we can
try the base room again maybe it's in the base room where is
the base room maybe it's in the base six cents six cents all
right there has to all right we're gonna go we're gonna do a
checklist we'll do a little checklist we'll do a base room
first this is a tutorial okay an and we always it's fine
it's fine you know that me we can start from the beginning
again whenever you're lost you have to reveal yourself then
you have to remember how did you actually start oh my god i
like how it's important i like how we really important here
here here here here here here
okay what you found it it was here all of a lie i'm happy
i'm
happy let's go let's finish this we got this you know we can
finish it we can do it oh my god it was in a fucking we were
in this room before for so long it was in there okay body
room where's the body room No,
that's the red door.
That's the door.
Around here.
Yeah, is it here?
No, that's the tutorial.
Let's go back to the red room again.
you're in the tutorial.
Where was the body room again?
Where was the body room?
Where is it?
Did I pick it up?
I did.
I can't believe.
Oh, my God.
I'm in the mirror room.
Where am I?
I'm so lost.
Here.
No, I'm here.
here not here not here not here not here not here not here
not here not here oh my god
i'm not okay i'm not okay you said
it's okay everything is okay i still have my one almond
water
Okay We're fine.
You said we're fine.
We're fine.
We're okay.
There is the enemy.
I found I found it I found it.
I found it.
Oh my god.
Okay.
What was their name?
It was like Leah or some shit Lena Lena Lena Lena Lena Oh my
god, mirror mirror will
go.
I heard the sound What what do you see?
what's what happened oh my god we did it we did it we
finished this puzzle we got to go find we did it oh my god
mirror room i heard it proud of ourself let's go let's go to
the mirror room you son let's go follow me follow me follow
me i'll be responsible for this don't worry it's be fine
okay we did this here here so get fine in the mirror room
there we go there we go here here yeah here come here come
here you said the door is open look oh oh this is new oh
what the i don't like anything new i don't like anything new
oh How do I use this?
Okay, interact.
Interact.
How do I use the screwdriver?
Screwdriver, I don't have it.
No, I do, but how do I use it?
Oh my god.
Is there a fuse?
No, I don't have fuse too.
Yellow?
No, I can't open that.
Red?
What was the color?
What did those colors go?
I don't know.
We need fuses, but I don't try to find where the fuses are.
Yeah, I have nothing in my inventory right now.
It's pretty empty.
Okay, I have everything.
Wait, maybe this?
Okay, what's this?
What about this?
There are multiple layers that are in stone too, but only
three.
can be up at the same time oh okay but what color what color
do they have to be i have no idea oh oh okay wait okay wait
i get it i get it i get it okay okay it's not this one all
right okay go come go come to go to the door go to the door
and then i'm gonna Go to the door and tell me if it's green.
Go to the door and start go to the door Which door?
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I'll go to the door.
I'm gonna go to the door and then you flip the switches and
I'll tell you if it's a green I'll tell you if it's a yes or
no Okay, okay So which so come here.
Come here.
You saw it.
Okay, so you see this door?
Okay, so I One of my switches I did was correct.
So I want you to keep doing...
You can only have three switches at the same time.
So you turn on the switch.
Each switch.
And I'll tell you if it's yes or no.
If it's no, turn it off.
If it's yes, keep it on.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
All right, all right.
Use the walkie-talkie.
Okay.
All right, all right.
All right, go, go, go.
So...
I'm just gonna...
Up-deliver, right?
Yeah, yeah.
In the rack.
How about this?
No.
Turn it off.
Okay, I just...
Yeah.
Uh...
How about this?
No.
Turn it off.
Wait, yes, yes!
Yes!
Oh, no.
Yeah, wait, don't...
Turn it back up!
Yeah!
We need one more.
It's not working.
Oh, you have to turn...
Like, one of them is not working.
Oh, okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
I know which one.
think wait like this one's not working let me let me try let
me try i think it was this one is this yes or no oh this was
yes this was yes okay we need to turn off one more turn off
we turn on we need to turn on sorry we need to turn on okay
so this one we ignore that
wait it's fine it's fine No, it's not fine.
It's not fine.
Oh my god.
I can see any shit.
Anxiety peel.
Oh my god.
Okay, I know which one.
Okay.
This is... Yes.
I need to turn off one more.
Oh, this one.
Okay.
Oh, okay, I did it.
Awesome.
sorry that was hard yay wait there's a radiation suit we did
it bro i need your pill oh my god oh we did it put it on put
it on put it on come down i need to heal myself like real
quick i don't remember what these do what okay Okay,
awesome.
Oh, yeah, we did it.
Put it on.
Put it in your inventory.
Oh, open your inventory and put it on.
Oh, okay.
I thought I'd put it on right.
Equip.
How about this?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We did it.
Guys, I need to know how much more do we have of this stuff
at this level?
I have no idea.
We're going to figure it out.
You don't have it on yet.
You don't have your radiation suit on.
Well, I thought I have my suit on.
Wait, do you, does it look like, do I have my suit on?
You are.
Yeah, wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, you don't.
I equipped it already.
Wait, use, use.
Yeah, there we go.
Whoa, yo.
Okay.
Looking pretty handsome in that suit.
We have two more puzzles.
We have two more puzzles, Yusai.
Oh, my goodness.
Okay, base room.
Radiation room.
We need to find the radiation room.
God, where was that?
I don't remember where it was that.
It's not this way!
Okay, now, now figure it out.
Okay, follow me.
Follow my six cents.
Okay.
Here we go.
Here.
Oh, that's the red room.
That's the red room.
Oh.
Oh my god, that is...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, here!
We can go!
Nice, awesome.
Here, here.
do it no no all the way all the way there oh yeah yeah no no
this is vase room no no radiation rooms here but there's a
it's right here but there's a red light whoa okay i guess we
just go through i found it i found it here yeah all right i
need to read this again okay okay oh there's a locker that
only will open the radiation room is on low level achieve
this the class is required only many of those trees some
items on the rooms are contaminated oh okay so what we need
to do is find the items with the most contamination with the
most radiation oh so i need to use this has this is four
four all right so wait what is this it's the okay this one
has a lot of radiation I found one has a lot of radiation
and then we spray it okay I got it there you go yeah okay
that gas mask has a lot of radiation whoa whoa
there's a monster here I hear the footstep I hear the
footstep yeah me too I do too I don't like that I don't like
that.
I don't like that, too.
That's the door.
Okay, does this have radiation?
No.
Okay.
All right.
Wait, what was this?
Teddy bear.
Radiation?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Spray it.
Spray it with your extinguisher.
Okay.
Hold on a moment.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Use...
and then did you spray i did that he's spraying he's
spraying okay nice this one too this one too okay spray it
okay nice all right oh my god this game was like a lot of
things to do what about this one yeah yeah yeah all right i
don't know i think that's i want to check Let's I'm gonna
check the door.
Oh, we should have sprayed the door.
We should have we should have we should have okay This one
this one choose Okay Okay This this Okay All right, I'm
trying to figure out this the wheelchair Okay Nice this one
too the horsey Are we displaying just every item?
We have to go back.
We have to go back We have to find the door.
We have to find the door.
Where's the door?
I see the yellow door.
Oh, here, here.
Wait, spray the door.
Wait, what?
No, we needed one, two more items!
No!
What are you saying?
We gotta spray the door.
I thought we did it!
What did... What did I do wrong?
Did I do something wrong?
find enough items.
Oh shit.
Whoops, I dropped it.
No!
We need to find two more items that's contaminated.
I thought we found it all.
Two more.
Yeah, we need to find two more.
Ah!
No, I didn't find all of them.
How about this?
No.
Here?
Looking?
This one?
Come.
How about here?
How about this area?
No, I didn't.
There's none.
There's none here.
Okay.
I'm looking.
What the fuck?
Is it here?
Can I just spray every item we see?
No.
I mean, technically, yeah.
Right.
we can but like I feel like I feel like that's I feel like
that's gonna like make it harder for us where the fuck were
with the last two items no the three we couldn't I don't
know where the last two items are I can't find it where's
the That's radioactive!
No, that's the locker.
It's all...
Oh my god.
Okay, wait, wait.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna use the spray can.
Oh yeah, it's true.
Yeah.
I'm gonna use the... Okay, we gotta mark the door.
We're gonna mark the door.
Okay.
We have to find... Okay, find the raid...
Oh shit!
Oh god, that scared me.
That's a smiley face in there.
Don't look.
Oh no.
cup in corner next to the chair there's a cup in the corner
what oh my god what is it I heard the dog go no not the dog
go leave us alone leave us alone okay wait let's mark the
items first yeah okay this one is mark this item was
radioactive can you mark it okay okay yeah yeah what a spray
can i have no spray can oh wait what okay okay here i'm
gonna drop my spray can here you go all right cup is in the
similar i can pick it up why what wait what happened to your
spray can i I can't pick it up for the moment.
Okay.
Well, I can pick it up.
Oh, I think I got too much item out of the way.
So, I'm going to drop one of the invite appeal.
No, I believe I can grab Mr. Ken right now.
Oh, it's the horse?
The horse?
Wait, wait, come with me.
Come with me.
I remember where the horse is.
Oh, the horse toy.
Yeah.
Okay, I didn't know.
I don't know where the horse is.
I forgot.
Yeah.
Where's the horse?
Oh, is it?
Is it here?
Yeah.
I found it.
Okay.
And where's the cup?
Cup.
Okay.
There's a cup somewhere.
Is it this?
No, that's Moth jelly.
Not here.
I'm just gonna go find a cup.
That's Moth jelly.
What do you mean?
Cup, cup, cup, cup, cup, cup.
Papers?
Here, is it?
Spray the paper, spray the paper.
How about this paper?
Spray- No!
Spray the paper!
Spray it!
Doki, doki!
Just spray it!
This one?
Spray everything!
Did it work?
I don't know!
I'm spraying everything I see!
No!
The thing!
time limit.
Just spray every item.
It doesn't matter anymore.
No.
Just spray every item you see.
We split up.
We split up and start spraying.
I'll just spray everything I see.
We split up.
It doesn't matter.
Yeah.
Just spray everything.
Eventually it will i've given up just spray everything
spray and pray
okay all right we we must be close all right so anyway i
just started blasting did you spray everything i just spray
everything i see as possible boy there's still six items
there's still working.
There's still six items.
It's not even working.
Keep spraying.
And just keep spraying.
Eventually it'll work.
Why?
Did it open?
Did you heard that?
I sprayed it alive.
open no it's four oh keep spraying it's my god
we have nothing else to play anymore there has to be more
wait this one is it
always more
there has to be more items you can find it you said I can't
walk through you saw I have no idea wait you saw you're
blocking the door I can't spray what about this what about
this
Just spray ourselves.
The paper must be radiated too.
I sprayed everything I swear to God.
Okay.
All right.
I'm just gonna...
Three items!
Oh, three items!
Three more!
Okay.
Two now, right?
Oh, let's see, let's see.
Okay.
No, still three more.
Spray everything.
Do the lockers get radiated?
Oh my god.
Spray everything.
Yeah.
I bet.
Okay.
Three more.
Still three more.
What about now?
Uh, two, two more, two more, two more, two more.
Where is the last two?
I swear to god I swear to fucking god Two more I found one I
did it!
I did it!
Spring every city!
Let's go!
Why is this so hard?
We did it!
Alright, there's a creature that wanders aimlessly on some
backroom zones.
It seems to have no conscience but until it's hungry.
At which point it becomes aggressive.
Venus looks for the closest subject to eat.
It distinguishes from other creatures that looks to skin its
victims.
Oh, okay.
And seal their skin.
It's reasoning that he can spell blood over long distance.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Did you get it?
Yeah, I did.
But, like, the next...
How do we open?
Oh, I did it.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
There is a progress.
We're doing...
I think we're doing fine.
No?
Oh, my God.
We're doing so well.
Yeah, we're going well.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Okay.
I'm a little worried, though.
Down?
Wait, are we gonna die if we go down?
I don't know.
No, don't do that.
Don't do that.
Wait, it's locked.
How do we... Wait, wait.
Wait.
Where are we going?
Well, I guess we go down.
Okay, let's go.
Did they die?
Now what?
We did it!
We beat the level!
You saw me!
We did it!
No!
Yeah!
And this is where we call it.
Okay.
Now what?
This is where we end the game.
The game?
Okay.
You know what?
I think it's fine.
I think we did really well.
I think you know we- I think so.
Yeah.
We spent two hours of stream and there are a lot of
progress.
Yeah, we make so much progress.
You know, yeah, we did.
Yeah.
We did us a lot.
I don't think we don't have to do everything if we, you
know, enjoy the game.
You know what?
I'm proud of myself.
You know, I'm proud of ourselves too.
We did so well.
We might have got stuck a lot, but you know what?
We did so well on easy.
We did so.
Even though it was easy mode, we were pretty good at this
game, right?
I don't believe that it was easy mode.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, guys, I was joking.
When I said it was easy, I meant hard.
We were definitely on hard mode, guys.
Yeah, you saw me.
Don't believe that.
That was a hard mode, okay, chat.
thank you for coming to this thank you for for playing with
me you son thank you too that was so much thank you very
much for being really patient at our game thank you so much
for backseating us but kindly you know i will give a credit
for you guys for your patience there's no fun base being
this much patient you guys are the best then you know what
have an awesome day yeah thank you guys thank you for coming
son thank you oh my god oh my god thank you everybody i'm
gonna talk to my chat real quick you son but thank you again
i really had a great by the way chat there's gonna be my 3d
concert yeah check out you saw 3d concert i am definitely
not here for self-promote because that's too much sacrifice
to myself, you know?
Just for fucking promotion, I sacrificed too much for
myself.
I killed so much brain cell for this.
But you know what?
I think I kind of, it was kind of worth it.
You know?
Alright.
I'll talk to you later.
Okay.
Bye-bye.
Oh my god.
I just, I just insta-quit.
I just quit the game
Holy shit that was so fun Oh my god I can't believe we beat
the tutorial I'm so Proud of us We did it We beat the
tutorial Oh my god Oh my god I can't believe I can't believe
a
decking tutorial i swear to fucking god i'm gonna oh where
am i whoa okay oh my god
oh thank you again to you son for joining me today that was
really fun um i'm gonna go read some oh my god i haven't
read super chats in so long give me a sec donation reading
time oh my gosh it's been a while since we did uh did like
donation reading so i'm gonna read some super chats um i'm
sorry if i can't get to a lot of the super chats today um
i'm a bit tired but i hope you guys had a lot of fun though
that was that was a little bit of a mess but we did it we
did it everybody we fucking beat the tutorial i'm so proud
of all of us.
I really am.
It truly was one of the hardest games I've ever played.
I can't believe how much we fucking struggle.
Oh my god.
Thank you for all the gifted memberships too.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you guys.
Alright.
Let's see.
NS5.
How's the backlog of Super Chat?
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
you it's like pretty rough it's a pretty rough backlog
they're so i really appreciate all the support i really do
appreciate it's it's a lot um thank you so much thank you
thank you mechanical land shark itoki what is your favorite
design of shockwave g1 prime cylinder oa or god forbid live
action i think like og the og one with the mask is my
favorite oh wait sorry that's sound wave I thought I said
sound wave.
I thought you said sound wave, not shock wave.
Shock wave?
I don't really care much about shock wave's design because
like shock wave wasn't really my favorite transformer.
I liked sound wave more than shock wave because like sound
wave was like a fucking DJ.
So like for me shock wave, I don't really care too much
about their design.
But if I had to pick, Prime, I think.
I think Shockwave Prime was a nice design.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Cold Death.
Otoki, you're really amazing.
We all support you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Let's see.
Phoenix, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Voitan, it was fun to see you, son.
You look for the exit in your average office building.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We got super fucking lost.
I swear to God.
to find the fucking i swear to god the amount times we got
we were just stuck in the tutorial the elevator beginning i
swear to god we are always stuck we always came back to the
elevator no matter what uh yusun thank you for the akasupa
thank you thank you thanks dragons thanks toky thank you for
the akas yes um make sure to check out yusan and And also
their covers, their music, and their original songs.
And also check out their first 3D concert that's coming up.
I don't remember when.
But like, it's coming up.
Seamun can't wait for part 2 of the tutorial.
I can't believe that was the tutorial.
Thank you, thank you.
Mr. Remember Doki, the tutorial was all the friends we made
along the way.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
stream any chance for dynasty warriors 3 someday uh thank
you thank you oh my god i can actually play like the good
dynasty boys
oh my god we can play the good ones oh my god maybe in the
future thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um
uh let's see where was i in the super chat
Doki, I think this is the dog.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mr. 2, we beat the tutorial.
Let's go!
I hope to see Yusun again.
It was fun.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I hope so too.
I hope we do more collabs in the future with Yusun.
Um, anime, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Watching y'all play was a roller coaster, but it was also so
much fun.
Keep being awesome.
Doki, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm glad you guys enjoyed that collab.
Um, it's nice to be able to collab with them.
to do lots of collabs with lots of different people in the
future uh saber vocal exercise thank you with a super chat
thank you thank you um i like how the only time i died was
when i just gave up i was just like i don't know where the
fucking eye is just just let this end me anime thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you watching all play was a
roller coaster also so much fun.
Wait, did I just read that?
I'm so sorry.
If I did, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Your first super chat, Adrian.
The two of you make up one brain cell in that tutorial.
Peak content.
Keep it up.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Poole V.
Thank you for the machenta soup.
Thank you.
Liquid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Howie Doki just got home from driving in the snowstorm and
had your stream playing in the background.
Let's focus on the road, of course.
Thank you for keeping me company.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm glad that I kept you company.
I'm glad you guys have all enjoyed today's stream.
That was really, really fun.
Before the stream, I was, like, super tired, too.
I feel like every time I'm not streaming, I'm just very
tired.
I was, like, so tired, like, physically and mentally.
And so I was just, like, oh, man.
Man, I hope I'll be able to stream.
I feel so tired.
Every time I turn on the stream, I just go like 100%.
I was just like, all right, let's go.
Let's fucking go.
I'm a content creator.
I got this.
I can do this.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
Welcome.
Also, welcome to the Amber Show.
Welcome to the Amber Show.
really appreciate it thank you thank you uh black thank you
the super chat thank you thank you sometimes when you're
lost it's great to go back at the start to figure out your
way you saw while being lost going back to the tutorial
thank you for this for the super chat thank you thank you i
can't believe okay nem thank you for the magenta soup but
thank you thank you i can't believe the eye was in the
locker the entire time i can't believe it the room we hid in
for so long we kept hiding in the room we kept hiding in and
it was in there the entire time i can't believe it none of
us looked at it we all did not think it was there i camped
in that room so fucking long and i didn't even realize it
was there
Andrew, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Horror games are scary, but your addicts and new sons
hyperventilation.
I honestly cannot take your fear seriously.
Thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, I'm gonna call it here now and rest up.
But thank you everybody for all the super chats.
I'm really sorry if I couldn't read yours in time.
But thank you everybody.
I really had an amazing time.
Hang out with everybody and playing this game with you, son.
I hope you guys had an amazing time with us.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
Have you stayed up for me?
Head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.